I'll try and be more obtuse with this
one uh no I'm gonna I'm gonna phone it
in hello you oh it's you yeah well no
it's just yes
[Music]
hi I'm Tilly keeper and I'm Penn Badgley
and we're playing uh First Impressions
with lad Bible
oh geez
um
what's an impression oh I gotta think of
something this person says
um
grab a bucket and a mop that's a lot oh
um um Megan the stallion well you're
very close rdb yeah your friend yeah yes
your good friend cardi B I wish I could
have done something better sorry
I think you'll get this one
I can't do a good question all right
oh is it um what John Lennon or
something or is it Bingo no it's
actually really not that um are you
actually one of this person's biggest
fans yeah I've spoke about it with you
it's fine if you don't remember it's
cool um
um I've got curly hair I've got curly
hair and I was recently in some films
and I was accused of spitting on Chris
Pine
but I didn't
I don't have any hair no it always does
yes
curly hair
nice
I don't want to get irate pen but yes
well you're irate
this is correct sweetheart
next one that was wow I didn't yeah he
doesn't speak like that but he doesn't
speak no oh uh
geez
um how do I do this one
oh that's painful that's not yeah
indigestion this is I'm indigestion
incarnate I thought that was the
impression you you like the show right
okay you like this the our show yeah you
know it yeah I know it okay sure
everybody wants to talk to 15 year olds
General tagus
that's the it's the most memorable line
I could think of that she says I know
this
okay wait wait wait because I actually
was quite surprised okay yeah there is a
baby llama in the desert is this
Lawrence Olivier
the big great whale swims to the shore
what on Earth yeah am I not doing a
great impression
think about the voice
yes and now the baby leopard takes it
um
it sounded more like um storytelling
than than a wildlife generation I mean
he's very much
I don't know how to do this one
um
well
I drove over no he's not worth uh he's
not worth the time of my day you see you
yeah
yeah so oh so is it you
what me next yeah no is it Tilly keeper
no no why because I thought maybe we
were you don't guess the game please
okay is this what we're doing now is
this
okay
but also
Jonathan you yes is it chili or Phoebe
well this is the game
um okay so it's Phoebe yeah
um okay this is uh
um
wow
how does one
um
I don't even know what he says don't
give up he's like
I'll see you again it's me yeah
um
Minnie Mouse Mickey Mouse okay
okay that was that's the content you
want right there
I think right oh
is this is this a British person I can't
answer it you can't I'm talking like
this and I'm a singer and I'm in Vegas
at the minute oh is it a deal yeah
the bitter she said that on the ground
Lawson
Adele you're not bitter I promise oh it
doesn't mean she's sweet I'll try and be
more obtuse with this one
um good
uh no I'm gonna I'm gonna phone it in
hello you oh it's you yeah well no it's
just yes
sorry very differently I really wish I
would have been able to think of like a
deep cut line but
yeah someone get me a pen someone get me
a pen I don't like this pen is it my
mother no I'm kidding obviously I would
lead this country
I mean is this uh Winston Churchill or
like I don't know no uh
right now it's happening right now is
your guy
yeah what's his name oh
um
oh it's royalty oh okay because I
was gonna say okay
I was gonna say Prince Charles yeah yeah
it was but they're not leading the
country he's a king king Prince oh my
goodness
oh yes yes
okay
what else could that be
Dragon dinosaur earlier well something
alive now
that seems very good but I don't know
what it is I also really channeled her
on the first day of filming and I was
like hold it back it was quite it's
quite heavy like it can only blunt no
um
um you're going to want to know
what it tastes like
this I'm doing a really good giveaway
right now yeah no that that feels so
familiar oh Keira Knightley yes
geez um
oh my God no um
I'm gonna look really hot when I do this
oh you get out of my swamp
thank you
um yeah about swamped are you the Loch
Ness monster Fiona Fiona Fiona
thank you
all right
I can't make noise right
it's me Mario okay
see ya
you know what I'm doing anyway don't you
what what surely go I'm going to bed
before either of you come up with
another clever idea to get us killed or
Worse expelled
um the uh I'm not an owl
I'm not an owl hermioneer